Let's have the molecule
sodium chloride.
Let's look at the
periodic table.
Sodium, it's in alkali metal.
It has one valence electron.
It's in Group 1.
And so when it only
has one, it really
wants to give it away.
And chlorine is a halogen,
and it's only one away.
It just needs one electron to
have the full eight valence
electrons in its outermost
shell.
So it really wants to
take 1 electron.
And we've talked about this
story multiple times,
especially it early in the
chemistry playlist. So what we
know what's going to happen.
Sodium, since it wants to lose
an electron, is going to lose
its electron.
And it's going to give
it to chlorine.
And chlorine is going
to gain it.
And so you're going to have a
situation where sodium is
going to have a plus 1 charge,
because it lost an electron.
And then chlorine will have a
minus 1 charge because it
gained an electron.
And then they'll be attracted to
each other because this one
is now a positive atom
and that one is
now a negative atom.
And just the Coulomb force will
make them want to be with
each other.
And we call this, of course,
an ionic bond.
I haven't taught you anything
you don't know yet.
And in an ionic bond, you
literally had a loss of
electron from one compound
to another.
Now.
that's a very cut-and-dry
situation.
But we saw other situations
where wasn't quite as
cut-and-dry.
For example, H2O.
Where you have a oxygen-- but
you've seen this multiple
times already, if
you're watching
this playlist in order.
And it's bonded to
2 hydrogens.
But we know that oxygen is much,
much more-- in fact,
nitrogen, oxygen, and fluorine
are the most electronegative
atoms, which means that they
like to hog electrons the
most. So when you have oxygen
bonded with pretty much
anything-- but in particular in
this case, hydrogen-- it's
going to to pull most of the
electrons in its direction.
So even though these are
covalent bonds, the hydrogen
is still sharing the
electrons that it
has bonded with oxygen.
The electrons spend most of
their time on the oxygen side
of this whole affair.
So you have a partial negative
charge on the oxygen end of
the molecule.
And you have partial positive
charges on the hydrogen.
And we talked about this.
And this is what leads
to hydrogen
bonding, and all of that.
What we're going to do here is
introduce-- it's almost an
intellectual tool.
We know that this isn't
an ionic bond.
We know that this is actually
a covalent bond, that this
atom is shared.
But it spends most of
its time at the more
electronegative atom.
That's why you have this partial
negative charge.
So we create this convention
called oxidation states.
Let me write that down.
And I'll clarify what the
word means in a second.
And this is essentially
assigning-- With an ionic
compound, you naturally assign
a charge, because each atom
really does have a charge.
But let's say we want to live in
a world where we don't like
this partial charge,
partial negative.
We want to say, look, if this
were, hypothetically, an ionic
bond, what would it look like?
Who would gain the
electron and who
would lose the electron?
So in the case of water, if you
were forced to say OK, who
gained the electron?
You'd say oxygen gained 2
electrons from the hydrogens,
and the hydrogens lost each
1 electron to the oxygen.
So the hydrogen would have a
plus 1 charge, each of them.
And then the oxygen would
have a minus 2 charge.
Now, I want to be very
clear with this.
This isn't what really
happened.
This is just our little
intellectual game that we're
playing called an
oxidation state.
It's going to be really useful
later to understand why some
reactions occur.
But I just want to
be very clear.
This is a hypothetical charge
if these were ionic bonds.
So you're just saying, whoever
is the more electronegative--
and remember, electronegativity,
it goes
from the bottom left
to the top right.
So these are the most
electronegative atoms, which
means they love to hog electrons
the most. These are
the least. Or you could also
call them the most
electropositive, which means
they like to give away
electrons the most.
So what you would do
is you say, OK.
The more electronegative,
let's just say that they
actually get the electrons.
And that the more
electropositive atoms, they
give the electrons.
Even though we know that it's
something in between.
It's actually partial.
Now these numbers.
These hypothetical ionization
of these hydrogen molecules.
This is called their
oxidation number.
The oxidation number of hydrogen
in H2O is plus 1.
So we could write a plus 1 for
each of the hydrogens there.
And then oxidation number for
the oxygen is minus 2.
And the way we talk about it,
we say that the hydrogen
molecules here have
been oxidized.
And it's kind of like saying
that you've been-- In this
case, they were oxidized
by oxygen.
And this is actually a very
confusing point, or at least
it was to me initially.
Because when I first learned
about oxidation, I was like,
oh, that's what oxygen
does to things.
Because the word has the word,
oxygen, or at least the
beginning part of oxygen.
So I thought, oh, oxidation must
mean what oxygen does to
other atoms, which
means it takes
electrons away from them.
Usually it takes 2 electrons
for itself.
Maybe it took 1 from each of the
other atoms. So if you've
been oxidized, you've had
electrons taken away from you.
And so you'll have a
positive charge.
Now, that interpretation
is only partially true.
The reality is it does not have
to be oxygen that's doing
the oxidation.
So for example, let me
do hydrogen fluoride.
H F.
I've shed my habit of writing
fluorine as Fl.
I've now remembered that its
elemental symbol is just F.
So hydrogen fluoride, if it was
in an aqueous solution,
it'd be hydrofluoric acid.
That's hydrogen here bonding
with fluorine, one of the most
electronegative atoms. So what's
going to happen here?
Once again, the reality is that
hydrogen is sharing--
it's a covalent bond
with fluorine.
But the electron spends most
of its time here, on the
fluorine atom.
So you're going to have a
partial negative charge here,
and a partial positive.
But we don't like this partial,
halfway game.
We want to say, look.
If this was, hypothetically, an
ionic bond, if one of these
people have to gain or
lose an electron, how
would it play out?
In that situation, this guy
likes to hog electrons more
than hydrogen does.
So the fluorine would gain an
electron and have an oxidation
number of minus 1.
And the hydrogen would lose
an electron, and have an
oxidation number of plus 1.
In this case, hydrogen
has been oxidized.
And notice, there's no
oxygen to be seen.
So the way I think about it,
fluorine did to hydrogen what
oxygen would have done.
For example.
If I say that you've been
Bernie Madoff'ed.
Bernie Madoff might not be the
actual individual who's taking
your money and putting it into
a Ponzi scheme, but it would
mean that someone else is doing
the same thing that
Bernie Madoff would
have done to you.
So in the same way, even though
there's no oxygen here,
fluorine has oxidized
the hydrogen.
Now, I'll introduce another
word, and that's reduction.
Reduction is the opposite
of oxidation.
I'll write it in blue.
And this just means a
reduction of charge.
So in this hydrogen fluorine
molecule, or hydrogen fluoride
molecule, hydrogen has
been oxidized.
It's been oxidized because
electrons have been
taken away from it.
That's what oxygen would
have done to it.
And so it has, now,
a positive charge.
And its oxidation number
is plus 1.
Because exactly one electron
would have been taken away
from this in a hypothetical
ionic bond.
Now, fluorine has
been reduced.
Its oxidation state
was reduced by 1.
If there was no hydrogen
around, it
would've been neutral.
But now it has a
minus 1 charge.
Because in our hypothetical
world of there's no partial
charge, it's more
electronegative.
It took the atom from
the hydrogen.
So it has a minus 1 charge.
Its charge has been reduced.
Its oxidation state
has been reduced.
Your oxidation state is just
that hypothetical charge.
And that's how I think of it.
Reduction means reduction in
your hypothetical charge.
Oxidation means, what would
oxygen have done do you?
Which means it would've taken
away electrons, which would
mean you have a positive
charge.
But if you look in some
textbooks, or some teachers,
they'll give you a mnemonic.
Leo the lion says, GER.
I'll say, says, in small,
because it's really irrelevant
to the mnemonic.
And this is just a way of
remembering that Leo means
Losing Electrons is equal
to Oxidation.
And that Gaining Electrons
is equal to Reduction.
Now, to me, when you first said,
oh wait, I'm gaining
electrons, but I'm
getting reduced.
What's getting reduced?
What's getting reduced is
your charge, because
electrons are negative.
You're gaining something
with a negative charge.
So that's where the reduction
comes from.
Oxygen comes from the fact that
oxygen will normally make
you lose electrons.
It will normally take electrons
away from you, even
though oxygen might
not have anything
to do with the reaction.
Now, we can look at the periodic
table, and we can
guess, in most molecules, what
an oxidation state of a given
atom will be.
All of these guys are
alkali earth metals.
And this is really a review.
It's kind of taught
as something new.
But we know all of these guys.
They love to give up electrons,
because that makes
them stable.
Because they have this one
electron in their outer shell.
So they tend to have an
oxidation state of plus 1,
which means that they tend
to give away an electron.
For example, if I write
sodium chloride.
In this case, the oxidation
state is truly reflective of
their charge.
Its charge is equal to
its oxidation state.
It gave away an electron.
And that's true for all of the
alkali metals right here.
Remember, I don't include
hydrogen there.
Because hydrogen is a little
bit of a special case.
It could have been thrown here
on the periodic table.
Because it has one electron in
its outermost shell, which is
just its only shell.
But it's also happy to get two,
and have a configuration
like helium.
So you can almost view it
as it's very close to
completing its shell.
So it sometimes has alkali
metal-type properties.
And sometimes it has halogen
properties, where it wants to
gain electrons.
So hydrogen-- Let's say hydrogen
is bonding with one
of these guys, right?
So let's say you had
lithium hydride.
So in this case, lithium,
is right here.
It loves to lose
its electrons.
So it'll lose its electron.
So it'll have an oxidation
state of plus 1.
And it will lose its electron
to hydrogen.
Because hydrogen is more
electronegative than lithium.
Because hydrogen, you give
it 1 electron then it has
electron configuration
like helium.
So hydrogen will be minus 1.
In this situation, hydrogen
bonds with people roughly on
the left-hand side of
the periodic table.
So lithium-- just to review
our terminology.
Lithium was oxidized
by the hydrogen.
Hydrogen was reduced
by the lithium.
Its charge went down.
Their oxidation number?
Plus 1 for the lithium, minus
1 for the hydrogen.
What is the total sum of
an oxidation state
for a neutral molecule?
In this case, you add up the
charges and you get, oh, it's
equal to 0.
And that's a big takeaway.
Then, in general, if you have
a neutral molecule-- let me
write that down.
I'll just say neutral
compound.
Then the oxidation
states add to 0.
And if you have a non-neutral
compound, if you have a plus 1
charge, the oxidation states
of all of the molecules in
your compound are going to
add up to your charge.
Well, let me give
another example.
So in this case, I had hydrogen
bonding with these guys.
In that case, hydrogen is the
one that took the electron.
Let's say I had OH minus.
So hydrogen, in this case,
when it's dealing with
something that's not on the
left-hand side, when it's
dealing with a super
electronegative atom,
hydrogen's oxidation
state is plus 1.
Right?
Now, oxygen's typical oxidation
state, when it bonds
with almost everything else--
and I'll give a special case
in a few moments-- is minus 2.
Because it normally takes two
electrons from other things.
We saw that with the water.
Oxygen's oxidation state, in
most cases, is minus 2.
So even though it hasn't gained
two electrons here, we
would write its oxidation
number as
minus 2 for the oxygen.
And then you add up the
two oxidation states,
minus 2 plus 1.
Well, actually I'll
take that back.
Oxygen has gained an extra
electron because this is
already an ion.
So in this case, this OH, oxygen
has stolen an electron
from someone else.
Let me draw that.
And then oxygen normally only
has 1, 2, 3, 4-- so oxygen has
completed its valence shell.
So essentially, it took
an extra electron
from some place else.
So it definitely does have a
minus 2 charge in this case.
Oxygen has a minus 2 charge.
Hydrogen has a plus 1 charge,
because this electron was
taken from it by the oxygen.
And so the total charge of this
molecule is minus 2 plus
1, which is minus 1.
And that's why you have a
minus 1 charge on OH.
So you add up the oxidation
states, and you're going to
get the charge of the
atom under question.
Now, we already saw that most
of these guys have an
oxidation state of plus 1.
These guys here, the alkaline
earth metals, have an oxygen
state of plus 2, because they
like to give away two atoms.
We already saw hydrogen.
If they bond with people here,
they take the electrons.
So they get reduced.
So it has an oxidation
state of minus 1.
But if hydrogen bonds with these
guys on the right-hand
side, it gives away
the electrons.
So it would have an oxidation
state of plus 1.
We saw that with hydrogen
fluoride.
It would be the case
with hydrogen
chloride, hydrogen bromide.
You saw the case with water.
All of these cases, hydrogen is
the one that's giving away
the electrons.
So it gets oxidized.
And these guys get reduced, or
their the oxidizing agent.
Now, what about these
guys over here?
What about our halogens?
Well, they all like
to take electrons.
So their typical oxidation
state is minus 1.
Oxygen's typical oxidation
state?
We just saw it's minus 2.
And I'll show you an example,
which is really one of the few
cases where oxygen
doesn't have a
minus 2 oxidation state.
And then there's a lot of
these other elements, in
between, that can have multiple
different oxidation states.
And we'll see that in
a lot of examples.
But if you know that hydrogen
is plus or minus 1, if
hydrogen is bonding with these
guys, it's a plus 1. it gives
away electrons.
If it bonds with these
guys, it's a minus 1.
it takes the electrons.
If you know oxygen tends to take
two electrons, so it has
a minus 2 oxidation state.
And the halogens take one.
If you know that, you can
normally figure out all of the
other people in the compound.
So what I'll do is I'll leave
you there for now.
I realize I'm running
over time.
In the next video, we're going
to do some maybe more
difficult examples.